you've probably seen your friends  posting bright and beautiful pictures  created using the application lenser in  order to get your own colorful portrait  you simply have to upload a couple of  your own photos to the app lens then  copies the style of illustrations it  finds on the internet and gives you a  magic Avatar users were Amazed by the  results but then they began to realize  that they had willingly handed over to  the company not just their personal  information like their email address or  bank card details  but also their biometric data  what will the developers at lenser do  with them well the creators of lenser  claim that they delete your photos after  the AI has finished creating your avatar  but of course they still own the rights  to the avatars themselves you can only  hope that your biometric data won't be  stolen or sold do you use lenser what do  you think about this application